Speaker 1: Mike Pence failed. Former Vice
President Mike Pence was interviewed yesterday
and he was asked if Trump is the nominee in 2024,
will you vote for him now? Remember? Trumpists
are the people who were shouting Hang Mike Pence
on January 6th. Trump is the guy who completely
turned on Pence because Pence wasn't willing nor
able, by the way, wasn't willing, as Trump says,
to do the right thing to try to steal an election
for Trump that he didn't actually win. And here is
what Mike Pence has to say when asked about this.
Speaker 3: If Donald Trump is the Republican
nominee for president in
2024, will you vote for him?
Speaker 4: Well, there might be
somebody else. I'd prefer more.
Speaker 3: Okay.
Speaker 4:
You know, what I can tell you is I have every
confidence that the Republican Party is going
to sort out leadership. All my focus has been
on the midterm elections and it'll stay that
way for the next 20 days. But after that, we'll be
thinking about the future, ours and the nations.
Speaker 1: And yeah, so first of all, he's
sort of saying, I might be running. I mean,
to some degree, what Mike Pence is saying is there
might be someone on the ballot. I prefer like
myself when he says we're going to be thinking
about our future and the nation's. He's saying,
I'm going to be thinking about what I
want to do in 2024. Regardless of that,
there are two interpretations here and they can
both be correct. On the one hand, it is very clear
that Pence is off the Trump train and is trying
to figure out the right way to get off without
derailing his own political career. That's number
one. On the other hand. His supporters were saying
they wanted to hang you. And the strongest thing
you're willing to say is there might be someone
else who I would prefer more. So you can interpret
this, however, strikes your fancy. Right, on the
one hand may be the strongest anti-Trump language
we've heard from any of the major figures of the
Republican Party for the last year and a half.
On the other hand, his support Trump supporters
wanted to hang this guy and this is all that he's
willing or able to muster up. It's all pretty sad,
but an indication that the 2024 Republican
primary may become very interesting very
quickly right after the midterms that are now
just 19 or 20 days away. Let me know what you
think. Find me on Twitter at David Pakman.
We'll take a quick break and be right back.